okay everybody as bill mentioned my name
is Ben gable I'm a partner developer
advocate and game developer at Google
and I'm working on the initiative of
Chromebooks and games on Chromebooks and
basically we're super excited about this
opportunity and we're gonna go over to
the chromeless a little bit of overview
of the Chrome OS then we're gonna hear
from Daniel about Star Wars Galaxies of
Heroes and how they optimized the game
for Chromebooks and I'm gonna talk a
little bit about the technical overview
of things you might look out for when
optimizing your game for Chromebooks so
as you mentioned as some of you might
know or may not know you can now all
Chromebooks launched in 2017 and later
now support contain art plus plus and so
they've got a Android container running
in it and they can play Android apps and
games natively so this is super exciting
because now you can play on your mobile
device and on a PC like form factor and
this is something that's important
because it's not just Chromebooks
there's also there's a push and I think
in the entire industry where think you
know we're pushing towards just like a
universal app type thing where you can
play on your mobile device you can play
using like Samsung decks on a PC type
experience so it's important to think
about this moving forward that users are
really gonna expect to play their game
on the go and then maybe at home plug
into some device or load it up on
another like different form factor
device and continue playing from where
they left off so and of course we're all
gamers so I think some of us might argue
that playing on a keyboard a mouse is
the only way to play so super exciting
for that reason as well just a little
bit about the momentum of Chromebooks so
you know this is just rolled out in 2017
and you know we overtook max in the US
in 2016 it's a huge player in the in the
educational space so a lot of schools
are buying Chromebooks obviously not to
play games on them but you know hey and
it's growing and Google's putting a lot
of effort in kind of making Chromebooks
a huge success and so some of the common
issues that we run into when
optimized Android apps for Chromebooks
is obviously you've got a bigger screen
increased resolutions your default to
landscape orientation now instead of
portrait
you've got windowing that can take into
consideration and then also you've got
keyboard and mouse controls and while
these are common issues for games
there's a lot of opportunities so you
know you can avoid the hand claw playing
in these hi-fi immersive games that kind
of now you could play for hours on end
you can avoid cramping your hand you've
got a bigger screen so UI is more
readable it does its job better it's
more functional and obviously keyboard
and mouse means you've got more
accessibility better controls especially
in competitive type games or really any
type of game but we've got somebody here
who has more experience and can give us
a first-hand look at how they optimize
it so I'd like to welcome Daniel up from
EA and he's going to talk about how they
optimized Star Wars Galaxies of heroes
to make an awesome Chromebook experience
all right Thank You Ben yep all right
I'm Daniel Levi with Electronic Arts and
I work on Star Wars Galaxies of heroes
recently I've had the exciting
opportunity to work with Ben to get Star
Wars Galaxies of heroes Chromebook ready
now out of the box if you've got a unity
title you are gonna be pretty far along
in terms of what you need to do to
support the Chromebook but we're going
to go over today a few best practices
and key considerations that we've
learned at Electronic Arts when
designing new features and retrofitting
existing features for the Chromebook
platform so just a little bit of
background if you're not familiar with
Star Wars Galaxies of heroes we provide
a mobile CCG collectible card game
collectible character game with strong
RPG elements and mechanics we let
players collect their favorite
characters and ships across a wide
variety of timelines within the entire
Star Wars universe through use of the
Unity game engine
we support iOS Android and as we'll see
the Chromebook though our worldwide
launch was in November of 2015
more recently in November of 2017 we've
added support for keyboard focused
features which we'll get into in a
second here so if you're an existing
life title you're probably thinking why
would I retrofit keyboard support
why would I rethink the features in my
game and engineer them and redesign them
around keyboards there's quite a bit of
technical jargon here but really the
core is consistently we've seen month
over month a growth and key indicators
that are important to game developers
our daily active users on Chromebook
have grown month over month and we've
also seen just specific to the
Chromebook platform or gross revenue
increase and again as we stated earlier
if you're a unity title you're 80
percent of the way there to supporting a
great experience on the Chromebook
platform now you're probably thinking
this sounds great how do I start
redesigning my features or integrating
support for new features around the
Chromebook platform there are a couple
pillars that we consider in redesigning
and creating new features that are
keyboard focused one of the key things
and this is going to seem somewhat
obvious but keep it in mind focus on
wide audience value what do we mean by
wide audience value if you're designing
a new feature in your game don't design
that feature such that it's entirely
specific to keyboard functionality think
about new features when you're
supporting keyboard functionality that
add value to both existing users of your
game and new players that are going to
want to interact with your game on a
keyboard this provides an easy
justification to your development team
and makes this sidequest easier to
justify in terms of development cost
another important item to note look at
existing features and functionality in
your game you might have a lot of
existing features such as in-game chat
that are so close to being ready for a
great keyboard experience take those
features don't ignore polish and take
them to the next level so that you can
provide a great keyboard experience now
this is important to any level of game
development
listen to your player base you'll be
surprised if you go on the Star Wars
Galaxies of Heroes subreddit and you
search for Android emulator or keyboard
you're gonna find a plethora of posts
from users talking about macros that
they've set up in game or how they're
engaging with the game using a keyboard
will see a specific example later on
where we drew from this player based
feedback to design one of our keyboard
first features so our first case study
here is roster search this is to me an
excellent example of a way that we're
able to provide wide audience value in
our game we both provided value for non
keyboard users and keyboard users if
you've played Star Wars Galaxies of
Heroes or for that matter any CCG you
know that there's a strong collection
mechanic here Star Wars Galaxies of
Heroes has hundreds of characters
hundreds of ships in each of those
characters and ships have a unique set
of abilities that have a unique way of
interacting with combat mechanics in the
game even more so we design events and
raids that specifically key off of those
certain ability mechanics of certain
characters so a lot of times we would
find players would go into a certain
event and they would ask hey you know
what are the best set of characters that
I want to bring into my squad for this
event they would analyze the meta they'd
understand what to do with respect to
that event but then they would get down
to the actual squad selection and they
would find themselves in undated with a
roster scroll list that they would have
to flick through to find their
characters or ships to assign to their
squad for that event so we designed a
roster search filter which for non
keyboard users gives quick access for
selecting different classifications and
factions of characters and for keyboard
users allows them to quickly type and
search for any different type of
characters they're looking for and this
is a feature that we've gotten great
feedback on that's provided value to
both types of users now our next case
study and this is the one that I'm kind
of most excited about is battle keyboard
bindings
this goes back to the social media
aspect here everybody on the subreddit
who's talking about emulators is saying
they're using emulators for faster
combat better interaction with their
characters ease of ability switching and
from that we were able to build this
piece of functionality that exists on
top of our existing battle function so
listen to your player base and design
new and exciting ways to interact with
your existing game features that are
very keyboard focused and provide a
better experience finally and this one's
going to seem really obvious almost
every game out there has some sort of
in-game chat functionality but this in
my mind is the perfect example of why
polish is important let's say you take
the base game with chat functionality
you're in battle you see a chat UI icon
you're able to open a chat dialog and
you're able to interact with your guild
now there are a couple of pieces of
friction within that flow you have to
first tap the icon go into the prompt
focus the text entry box and then start
typing
that's not keyboard focus design we have
the ability to detect these keyboard
users so let's take advantage of that
let's give these users a space bar macro
for example that allows them to easily
open and close the chat dialog let's
detect if these users have a keyboard
and then let's automatically focus the
text entry box so that they can
immediately start typing and interacting
with the chat feature those are very
simple pieces of work very low lift low
effort but they improve the keyboard
experience just that much more in
addition to these key considerations for
designing your features or new features
around keyboard focus design there are
additionally a number of special
considerations that we've encountered
one key thing that many unity developers
probably have already encountered is the
concept of key code escape now out of
the box
unity is going to surface the hardware
back button and the hardware Escape key
on a Chromebook keyboard
as the same input event as a key code
escape so one thing that you can do to
work around this is extend your Android
activity for your unity app handle input
there around these two cases and then
trampoline those values back to your
manage game code another option to
consider is a compromise for your Escape
key and your Hardware back button
functionality consider prompting the
user instead of just hard quitting or
hard minimizing out of the application
another key consideration is that of
unity iOS keyboard support this is
really important to keep in mind I've
talked to a number of people who have
you know developed around keyboard entry
they take an iPad they get a Bluetooth
keyboard
hook up the Bluetooth keyboards see that
they can enter emails and iMessage enter
the game and have no idea why their
keyboard functionality isn't working
unfortunately right now there are some
limitations around how bluetooth input
is handled on iOS devices specifically
with respect to you how unity surfaces
those input events so I suggest for the
time being if you detect that the device
is arc compatible by default enable
keyboard features get your keyboard
users into those keyboard features that
you've spent all this time polishing if
it's a general Android device which is
standard compliant with Bluetooth
keyboards default your keyboard
functionality off and give users an
option to then enable keyboard
functionality if they want to on an iOS
device however at this time I recommend
disabling keyboard input because it can
provide a confusing experience to users
now we've got a lot of engineers in the
room so this is preaching to the choir
and I apologize but as with any sort of
sidequest project or any sort of support
or retrofitting around a new platform
focus on minimizing coupling and ensure
maintainability that's a lot of words
there's a lot of jargon there let me
give you a specific example of that
going back to the battle keyboard
bindings
now I know many people in the audience
are probably thinking about how they
might implement something like this in
their own game right now and there are
many ways to do so one of the first
approaches which might be somewhat naive
with respect to the statement is taking
those battle ability icons and directly
coupling the display and functionality
of those keyboard macros with the battle
ability icons now that's probably an
easy way to get this functionality
started and get it going in your game
however the downside is now you've
introduced a coupling between your
keyboard functionality and the core
mechanics of battle in your game this
isn't good you're gonna end up in a
situation where you've pat yourself on
the back you've got an awesome keyboard
focused features in your game you have
Chromebooks support months in the future
and engineers going to roll onto the
project they're gonna have to redesign
some core mechanic of your battle
ability system and they're going to be
stuck maintaining your keyboard binding
code so instead for this example
consider having an overlay where you pin
those UI elements on the abilities
detect them at the time that you're in
battle and then do something like
simulate an input press it's not exactly
elegant but it at least removes the
coupling from your keyboard
functionality and your battle ability
system now I'm going to turn the
microphone back over to Ben for some
more technical considerations thanks
Daniel
all right so you know as we saw from
Daniel you know thinking about how you
can optimize your game on this new form
factor is really a huge benefit and
there's a lot of possibility there so
we're gonna go over some of the
technical aspects you should consider
when optimizing your game for
Chromebooks so first off it's the real
Android so it is Android running side by
side with Chrome OS and Chromebooks so
you've got access to all the things you
would expect in Android and as Dan
mentioned you know the first step is
kind of already done for you so if your
app is published on the place so right
now it's already running on Chromebooks
that might freak some of you out but
don't worry you know I would say you're
probably 80 to 90% of the way there
you're using the same apk for both
mobile devices and Chromebooks so let's
go over some common issues some best
practices and some of the testing and
tools that you have available when
optimizing for Chrome OS so the first
thing we're going to talk about is
target SDK version and six four bit
supports so this Chrome OS is currently
running Android and P is coming later
this summer which is awesome because
there's some cool mouse capture api's we
have there but you have to target at
least API level 24 yeah in order to get
all the preform resizing functionality
in your game if you don't do that your
game will restart whenever you get a
configuration change so it's important
to target at least 24 but as mentioned
earlier this fall we're going to require
you to target Android Oh so it's good
idea to start working on this now rather
than later your minimum API level
doesn't need to change and some things
you might run into our permission
updates we've talked about earlier and
some background execution changes as
well so first thing you should you start
looking at your target SDK version so
some features and sensors are actually
incompatible with Chromebooks so if
you're for example if your game is
asking for using GPS or NFC or stuff
like that those are not supported on
Chrome
so it's gonna show up as not compatible
with your device on the Playstore so you
want to make sure that you remove those
permissions if you're not using them or
add required equals false in order to
prevent it from being filtered out on
the Play Store for any Chromebook users
if you do that however just make sure to
dynamically check in your code these
features are available before you try to
use them otherwise things will blow up
that's never fun and some permissions
also implied feature requirements so if
your it's kind of a small list it's on
the developer page but if you're asking
for any kind of looking for like sms's
or you know stuff like that to send out
maybe invites to friends lists or
whatever your app will be filtered from
Chromebooks so it's important to disturb
will check your permissions and features
to make sure there's nothing that could
be filtering it out on Chromebooks so
the other big set of common issues
around the display so dynamic resizing
by default is enabled if your API level
target is greater than 24 so in a lot of
cases this can call cause flickering or
texture stretching and especially with a
lot of game engines you know it doesn't
handle it very well because in the
gaming world you know PC we kind of
expect things to be at a set resolution
and ass lock aspect ratio so what we
kind of recommend is that if you can't
support dynamic resizing which we
encourage you to take a look at you can
always set resizable activity equal to
false in your manifest in order to
prevent you Chrome OS from allowing your
app to dynamically resize one thing you
should keep a note is that it has to be
on the route activity so I've seen some
cases where if you happen to use a
different launch mode or something it
will ignore this setting so you have to
make sure that that is set on your route
activity another thing to take into
account is that Chromebooks are
convertibles you know you can put them
in laptop mode tablet mode and
upside-down apps are bad so how do we
prevent this so basically what you want
to do is if you are checking in your
code for and determining the orientation
based on that you want
sure that you're using display get
rotation and you're taking account that
portrait mode might not always be in
rotation zero so you want to swap your
axis accordingly if you are doing this
in code dynamically because it's gonna
be different from your mobile device to
Chromebooks
however easiest way to get to handle
this is to just specify a sensor
orientations in your manifest so you can
specify portrait or landscape and then
if you do that just make sure that you
don't specify one thing in the manifest
and then try to do something different
in the code later on you'll make chrome
OS go crazy another thing to take into
account is that if you have a portrait
mode game and you play it in a
full-screen landscape setting you might
want to add some flowers or other cool
stuff on the sides there to prevent the
ugly black bars so it's just something
to think about
so another thing that's on Chrome OS is
input compatibility mode so what this
aims to do is it basically tries to just
make touch-based
games and apps just work which makes
sense because most of the gaps and games
on Google Play right now for mobile
devices only expect touch inputs so it
basically translates Mouse and trackpad
events to touch events under the hood
this might not be the best if you're
trying to actually you know optimize
your game and take advantage of Mouse
and trackpad events so what you can do
is you can tell Andrew or you can tell
Chrome OS you're targeting PC type
Hardware by specifying the following on
in your manifest and then you can check
the source of your motion events to
actually determine where this is coming
from so once you do that you can do
things like listen for Mouse you know
hovering scrolling stuff like that all
these nice things that users would
expect when playing with the mouse so a
really good example of this is minecraft
story mode telltale basically dynamic
each X to see if the user is playing
with the keyboard and mouse and if they
are they change the input mode to
basically support from their touch touch
based control scheme to their desktop PC
and mouse to type control scheme so
it really works really well and it's
seamlessly and so if you're looking for
a great example I recommend that you
check that out so let's talk about some
best practices now targeting compatible
Chromebooks
so not all Chromebooks are going to
support touch or I even have
touchscreens a lot on the new right now
but it's not something you should rely
on in the future so you should make sure
that you specify that you don't require
a touchscreen because of the fake touch
feature otherwise again your app or game
will get filtered out from the Google
Play Store you can also extend this but
if you want to exclude specific devices
you can always do so through the Google
Play console but you recommend that you
try to support as many device as
possible so mouse and keyboard probably
one of the biggest best practices we can
suggest it's a support mouse and
keyboard so what does that actually mean
well well
detecting clamshell versus tablet is one
showing contextual control prompts and
consider accessibility menus and UI so
again asphalt 8 the text that you're
using a keyboard when you start up the
game and it will actually show you your
control scheme based on which control
scheme you're using so if you're playing
in tablet mode which works great not so
great when you're playing with a laptop
so they will change the control prompts
when you're playing to keyboard and
mouse that users are confused when they
are sitting there and they're like what
do I have to pick up my laptop and play
with it so definitely keep that in mind
if you're using unity luckily detecting
mouse and keyboard is pretty easy you
can just use the standard input class to
detect keyboard and mouse input if
you're using Java you can do something a
little bit more interesting where
basically you can you can pull the input
manager and basically figure out if your
device has a hardware keyboard and mouse
and then maybe toggle some kind of input
mode to say I'm playing on a desktop
environment versus I'm playing on a
mobile device so those are some ideas on
how you might detect the different
environment you're in and providing the
right
while scheme for users and you know
Daniel kind of talked about some of
these ideas for you know keyboard but
things like skill keybindings navigation
menu navigation extra credit custom key
mappings these are all things that would
really be appreciated by users on Chrome
OS using game pads which some of you
might need supports up to four and he
uses all the standard API eyes for
reporting so you're good set there and
on performance front so Chromebooks
support the pixel books and some of the
newer cabbie Lake devices all support
bulk in 1.0 1.1 is coming soon so this
is rolling out across different devices
so definitely take advantage of that if
you can also try to provide an x86 build
there there's a lot of Chromebooks that
are they have x86 processors and there
is some overhead with Houdini arm
translations so just keep that in mind
that if you can its best to provide an
x86 build so that you can take advantage
of that and also you should be careful
with dynamic performance optimizations
in your game so Chrome OS is basically
using a compositor and it can totally
screw up you could get into situations
where you end up with quadruple
buffering based on how the compositor is
doing so you might want to think about
you know testing if you're doing any
kind of dynamic optimizations to make
sure that you could be getting
requesting buffers and getting them back
super fast and you might get one buffer
that takes it some time because of the
compositor so that could totally screw
up your dynamic performance
optimizations so that's something to
test and just keep in mind when you're
trying to optimize for Chrome OS so
testing and tools you want to make sure
that you test your old and new flows so
moving forward our goal is to keep
Chrome OS in line with your the Android
version in line with your mobile devices
so there's not a lot of big large
breaking changes but with that said when
you first start bringing your game over
to Chrome OS you want to make sure you
test you know the close button up in the
upper right corner make sure that your
app isn't dynamically resizable if
you're saying it's not resizable
minimizing maximizing x86 builds arm
builds you just want to make sure that
there's no gotchas
everything all the Android lifecycle is
the same across Android and Chrome OS so
it should all be the same but there
might be some gotchas you should just
test for and the Chrome OS emulator is
now available it's integrated with
Android studio and it has hardware
acceleration this is a great tool if
you're developing to quickly test you
know any kind of performance or issues
with your game and also big news is that
ADB over USB is now available previously
it's coming out to Chromebooks rolling
out to the different models previously
had to attach over Wi-Fi which obviously
is kind of not ideal in some cases but
we're slowly rolling this out and you
should watch the keynote later this week
for more information on this but this is
also a really big win for Chromebooks
and for profiling a pug debugging apk is
in Android studio three and up you can
now import any debuggable or unity great
any debuggable APK or unity Gradle
project and actually take advantage of
the Android profiler for things like CPU
memory network usage so that's super
it's a really handy tool and I recommend
you all check it out and we have a lot
of developer resources on developing and
optimizing for Chrome OS so I recommend
that you definitely go check out our
developer pages for all the even more
nitty gritty than this talk and also our
developer blog there's some very
specific posts that we've written on
specific aspects of Chromebooks so if
you're looking for more in-depth topics
or in-depth knowledge you should check
that out
so to recap you know we're really
excited about the possibility of
Chromebooks now she can play you know on
a mobile app take it to your big screen
at home on your Chromebook and it really
opens up I think the way you can present
using Chromebooks you can provide the
best possible experience for your mobile
game so and as we've seen we've got lots
of partners that are doing this and
taking advantage of it and they're
flying out it's a great opportunity like
our friends
roblox and they're funny how it's not a
lot of work you know 89% of the way
there just some keyboard mouse some
testing and now you've got this whole
new kind of set of users that are can
enjoy and play your game in your mobile
game in the best way possible so we're
super excited we think our partners are
excited and we hope you all take
advantage of it so as I mentioned
there's an i/o session later this week
where we're going to talk about not
specifically games but just kind of
chroma West in general there's a lot of
cool stuff that's going to be in that
talk so if you're going to i/o
definitely check it out and as a special
surprise
Chromebooks so we have a bunch of
Chromebooks and we're going to give one
to each company that is here today so
we're going to do is please come find me
during the mixer I'm going to be sitting
back over there with those boxes and one
represented from your country will give
you a Samsung Chromebook pro so we hope
that you guys take that back if you
already have one take another one test
on it you know please check it out and
we think that you'll be surprised that
you know how well it works and hopefully
it inspires all of you to optimize your
games for Chrome OS so thank you if
there's any questions I don't know if we
have any time seen the remember will
answer some right now Thanks
so I'm always looking for great Android
TV games for our shield TV and it seems
that with the lack of touchscreen
support you know you can't obviously
assume touchscreen support as you
mentioned with controller support hit
support how much overlap is there
between Android games for Chromebook and
android games for Android TV Android TV
I think so I'm not super familiar with
Android TV what the overlap is but I
think you know in general it's just
another it's another space where you're
not going to have a touchscreen or
you're gonna have to think about these
other methods of input that will just
make your game work if you don't have a
touchscreen I don't know if that answers
your question or like what specifically
do you overlap
for the recording
Android TV doesn't have icons that has
banners because it's a different format
the launcher is different the Leanback
launcher how much of what you do code
wise and design wise for games on Chrome
OS can you then take to make a great
game for Android TV I think it's all
work that all plays together so if
you're optimizing for Android TV and
you're adding all these keyboard and
mouse input or you know keyboard or
pointer inputs it all kind of filters
back into Chromebooks as well so
thinking about other you know
implementing in your game other methods
of input and other ways that users might
be interacting with your game it all
plays together into making kind of an
app that game that can run on any TV on
Chromebooks on tablets etc so thank you
in the back
are you guys gonna be putting together a
highlight reel of Chrome OS apps running
on our arm sorry Android running on
Chrome OS cuz that was our other thing
when we're trying to get our developers
to be excited about it like this is
another platform it's another chance for
you to reach more users yep but they
look at it they say well that's more
work yeah so we want to want to be able
to make sure it's something that we can
highlight when it's being put in well
and we can point to our other developers
and say that's what we're looking for
that's the kind of functionality that's
the sort of user the the galaxy of
Heroes examples were incredible like
that's the kind of stuff that our devs
need yeah so there is this is a real
that's happening at the i/o you know
that I believe will be uploaded to
YouTube as well you know have an IO
ticket also when you get the Chromebook
in the Google Play Store we're
highlighting games that I've been
optimized very well so it's actually you
know featured banner in there so you'd
be able to download apps and test them
out and just kind of see what other
games might be doing and how that you
could potentially take some those ideas
and filter it into your game fantastic
thanks any other questions
cool there's no more questions feel free
to shoot me an email
I'll be around at the next or two so
thanks a lot